the Steven Spielberg went looking for
someone to play miss Celie in the motion
picture the color purple Robert De Niro
didn't want to lose the weight so
instead he found what he was looking for
and a gifted young comedian who was
filling a Broadway house every night
with a one-woman show please help me
welcome the very gifted lady who happens
to be a friend of mine madam whoops
Whoopi Goldberg
you can tell religion you are this
wonderful
Thank You Robin now what does a fill
matter to do well a film editor takes
anywhere from 100,000 to a million feet
of film and whittled it down to a motion
picture or as I prefer to think of it it
takes a thousand or 100 feet of oh geez
hon Jude thousand feet of film and turns
it into thousand ten thousand feet of
grace I don't know about this stuff you
know I'm used to getting up here talking
this and follow what they're saying and
this year the following individuals have
been nominated for achievement and film
editing John bloom for a chorus line
Frederick Stine come William Stein Kemp
Pembroke herring and Sheldon Conn for
Out of Africa
Rudy fair and cassia fair for Prizzi's
honor
Henry Richardson for runaway train and
Tom Nobel for witness
oh yes okay okay look at the thing as
flesh and announce it announcer and the
winner is Tom noble food
is that Louisville is in Central America
filming the Mosquito Coast take that off
I'm sure that if Tom Noble were here he
would want to thank his mother as some
of us might have thanked ours
and so I'm sure that he would also want
to thank the Academy and mr. Nobel
congratulations